I don't worry about anything in the
Internet age I I've been online since
well since I was aware of 1985 in San
Francisco with an an apple macintosh and
back then it was just a black screen and
you typed and someone typed back and I
loved it I loved it it's changed
everything in my life it's um I would
not want to even be alive in an era that
did not have it because it is the it is
essential to our evolution as a species
it to me feels utterly inevitable we had
we have to have it because if you think
about it we've created a system where
there's some sort of a global caste
system what happens if you're the genius
nine-year-old girl living in a dirt-poor
unnamed country with nothing and there
is not one I trained on you and you
don't even know enough to hope but
you're a genius right and one day
someone drops from the clouds some
peculiar little durable computer thing
that you've never seen and you pick it
up and you poke at it and you kind of
figure it out and what you realize is
that this little thing connects you but
more than connecting you to other people
in the world it masks you now a lot of
people can be afraid of the masking
because people can misrepresent
themselves and they can pose as people
they're not well yeah that's true that's
true that's one side of it but the other
side of it is that it equalizes you and
if you happen to be a person who is not
equal
in the eyes of the greater society
that's a damn good thing because now
guess what you are you are you are every
bit as valid as the stanford graduate
and we have to have that not for
politically correct reasons i don't give
a about that but we have to have it
because these people contain essential
things essential things in order for us
to progress we need brilliance and
brilliance isn't fair and it's not
polite and it's not um we can't grow it
it happens it happens genius happens and
it doesn't always happen in a zip code
where we can access it therefore we kind
of need not to keep tabs on everybody
but we need to give them access to
everybody else so I think that the
Internet is our most profound and
beautiful achievement it is um it is it
is magnificent it is magnificent and
it's just a baby it's just a baby I
cannot wait until we can um we can we
can know things because we have the
internet as a layer of our of our
thinking that doesn't control us we
control it yet we don't have to be aware
of it you know it'll be like a suit that
really fits well